und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend ein terrorakt an dem man
sich noch jahrhundert erinnern wird
sagte heute präsident der see lenski
über die belagerung und zerstörung von
mario pohl die hafenstadt wird von den
russischen truppen jahr regelrecht
ausgehungert
allerdings kommen die russen nur mühsam
in die stadt hinein vielleicht scheuen
sie aber auch den häuserkampf in dieser
großstadt auch aus anderen städten gibt
es weiter berichte über schwere gefechte
von dem was ich in kleinen dörfern und
vororten abspielt wenn die russischen
truppen dort durchziehen erfährt man nur
wenig die ukrainische seite spricht von
vergewaltigungen und anderen gräueltaten
welche informationen und bilder und zum
kriegsgeschehen heute erreichten fast
petra auto zusammen
wo war hat schwere verbrennung ist seit
vier wochen im kinderkrankenhaus in kiew
sein vater und sein bruder sind
verbrannt im auto auf der flucht die
kinderstation im keller medikamente und
verbandsmaterial werden knapp kein guter
ort wenn man schwer krank ist
ständig luftangriffe bombardements und
diese kinder sind gezwungen im bunker zu
setzen bomben keller eignen sich nicht
für die behandlung von krebs oder
dialysepatienten von todkranken es ist
eine von vielen traurigen geschichten
dieses krieges der heute weiter geht
brutal wie jeden tag
das russische verteidigungsministerium
veröffentlicht wieder bilder von einem
angeblich weiteren angriff mit der
hyperschall rakete kinscher
kinscher die hyper v rakete zerstörte
ein großes treibstofflager der
ukrainischen streitkräfte in der nähe
von nikolai sch
miku live unweit vom schwarzen meer ganz
in der nähe hatten die russen erst in
der nacht zuvor eine ukrainische
militärkaserne bombardiert die soldaten
dort im schlaf überrascht und
wieder und wieder angriffe auf mario
pohl zerstört eines der größten
stahlwerke europas das schon die nazis
angegriffen hatten nun droht eine
umweltkatastrophe
die menschen die noch hier sind sie
kämpfen ums überleben heute berichte der
stadtrat dass immer mehr bewohnerinnen
und bewohner verschleppt werden in
abgelegene orte russlands
die blockade von mario pohl wird sich in
der geschichte der kriegsverbrechen
einnahmen machen zielinski greif durch
hat heute für nachrichtenkanäle n-tv
einheits programm bevor und er schreitet
auch ein gegen elf russland freundliche
parteien
der rat für nationale sicherheit und
verteidigung der ukraine hat beschlossen
angesichts der verflechtung mancher
politischer strukturen mit russland die
aktivität einiger politischer parteien
einzustellen für die zeit des krieges
krieg in der ukraine
für manche ist ihre herkunft heute
wichtiger denn je und sie lassen sich
die ukraine verewigen weil sie einfach
stolz sind auf ihr heimatland und
aus der küstenstadt und deshalb ist uns
jetzt unserer reporterin katrin
eigendorf zugeschaltet katrin du warst
heute im landesinneren unterwegs was
hast du da erlebt und erfahren
ja ich war heute in was nicht ins das
ist eine stadt die circa 100 kilometer
von odessa entfernt wir sind da
hingefahren weil dort eine russische
panzerkolonne auf die stadt zugerollt
ist die kam eben aus diesem öko live dem
ort wo diese kaserne angegriffen wurde
die panzerkolonne konnte gestoppt werden
von der armee von der ukrainischen armee
die haben die brücke die in die stadt
führt in die luft gesprengt und da
konnte man wirklich mal vor ort sehen es
sind nicht nur die großen städte in den
wirklich katastrophale zustände
herrschen sondern sind auch die vielen
kleinen dörfer hier im land viele häuser
wurden dort getroffen von russische
russischer artillerie die waren bei
einer frau die hat uns gezeigt die war
schon vor dem krieg sehr arm ihre
fenster waren zerstört ihre tür
rausgerissen es ist ja auch nicht warm
sondern ziemlich kalt das sind einfacher
menschen bauern die sich gar nicht
leisten können dass alles so schnell
wieder aufzubauen viele menschen mit
denen wir da gesprochen haben haben auch
gesagt sie versuchen sich jetzt auf die
flucht zu machen aber die angst ist doch
sehr groß dass dort wieder angriffe
erfolgen können im moment sind sie
relativ stolz also ist der bürgermeister
vor allen dingen relativ stolz dass er
die russische armee dort zurückschlagen
konnte aber natürlich um den preis die
eigene stadt halb zu zerstören
dankeschön katrin diese eindrücke aus
der ukraine
und in russland haben tut ihn und sein
system dafür gesorgt dass praktisch nur
noch seine sicht der dinge gefahrlos
verbreitet werden kann viele
journalisten und andere kritische
geister verlassen das land dazu gleich
ein gespräch mit der gründerin von dort
tv einem der letzten unabhängigen
privaten sender in russland der bis
zuletzt über die wahrheit dieses krieges
berichtete und nun erst einmal verstummt
ist zunächst aber einen bericht von
isabel timina über putins propaganda
methoden
das russische staatsfernsehen hat sein
programm geändert seit beginn der so
genannten sonderoperation in der ukraine
gibt es weniger unterhaltung die
nachrichten sind doppelt so lang
der russische reporter in mario pohl
zeigt die russischen hilfslieferungen
und diese dame darf ihre mutter in
moskau grüßen
mama mit uns ist alles gut
bei der pompösen feier im moskauer
luschniki stadion zum achten jahrestag
der krim aktion wiederholt putin seine
botschaft in der ukraine werde ein
völkermord an russen verhindert
die menschen gerade von diesem leiden zu
befreien von diesen genozid das ist der
hauptgrund und der wichtigste grund das
auslösende motiv und ziel der militär
operation die wir im don bass und in der
ukraine begonnen haben
millionen menschen hören täglich die
immer gleiche erzählung vom völkermord
in der ukraine und der bedrohung
russlands durch feinde von außen auf
verschiedenen kanälen finanziert vom
kreml
mir scheint dass das fernsehen recht
erfolgreich das gesellschaftliche
bewusstsein in russland trägt leider
denn wenn es das fernsehen nicht gäbe
würde es freie informationen geben und
die russische gesellschaft wäre darüber
erschreckt was sich derzeit in der
ukraine abspielt
doch die propaganda verfängt nicht bei
allen vor allem russlands jugend sucht
andere informationsquellen
ich schalte mein kritisches denken ein
ich nehme unsere quellen und
ausländische und ziehe dann meine
eigenen schlüsse
wir erfahren ja nicht die ganze wahrheit
zum einen und zweitens das belastet so
sehr und du fängst an nervös zu werden
doch nicht alle auf linien eines ist
auffällig putins sprache wird immer
martialisch in seiner letzten
video-botschaft ist von der fünften
kolonne die rede national verrätern die
russland von innen zerstören wollen
er hat beschlossen sagen wir einmal die
phraseologie von hitlers mein kampf zu
imitieren weil er denkt in diesen
kategorien
mir scheint dass sein bewusstsein in
vielen nicht durch lenin und stalin
schriften geprägt wurde sondern gerade
durch die arbeiten der nazis
putin erhöht den druck alle sollen auf
linie seien unabhängige medien sind
verboten einer der letzten freien sender
dawn tv ist gesperrt viele mitarbeiter
flohen ins ausland so auch anna monk wir
sprechen sie im exil
wird fürchterlicher druck ausgeübt der
repressionsapparat gehorcht schon keiner
logik und gesetzmäßigkeit mehr alle
werden bedroht die nicht einverstanden
sind und das sind alle die den krieg als
krieg bezeichnen und die politik des
staates für gefährlich halten
kein unabhängiger journalismus mehr die
gegner eingeschüchtert oder weggesperrt
und so dröhnt putins patriotische
propaganda maschinerie weiter mit vielen
nationalem pathos und den ständig
gleichen parolen
und die gründerin des sindersdorf
natalias in die jeweils uns zugeschaltet
natalia sind hier war
guten abend sie sind aus russland
geflohen wie auch viele ihrer
mitarbeiter wie viele andere
journalisten
es gibt im prinzip keine unabhängigen
medien dort mehr wer kritik äußert droht
ins gefängnis oder ins straflager
zukommt was ist aus russland geworden
eine lupenreine diktatur
also wahrscheinlich ist das schon lange
eine diktatur aber man kann nicht sagen
dass es keine unabhängige medien mehr
gibt es gibt ganz starke teams die immer
noch ihre arbeit verrichten es gibt
nicht viele davon aber es gibt sie und
sie sind in russland
wie er darauf dass sie ihre arbeit
fortsetzen es gibt sehr viele teams die
in außerhalb prozent arbeiten aber es
gibt immer noch die möglichkeit diese
informationen auch in russland zu
bekommen deswegen
dass die zuschauer die in russland
verblieben sind und das gibt sehr viele
davon es gibt viele die informationen
braucht man muss ihnen auch sagen was
passiert und alle strengen sich an um
die menschen möglichst gut zu
informieren
passiert das nicht nur probleme mit den
medien sondern sind probleme die wir
alle jetzt haben und die ganze welt hat
das ist die tragik
wenn sie darüber sprechen dass es immer
noch einzelne gibt die versuchen
unabhängig zu informieren stellt sich
auch die frage wie groß der anteil in
der russischen bevölkerung ist der dass
auch sucht es ist sehr schwer hier von
deutschland einzuschätzen aber es gibt
auch ein paar umfragen die zeigen dass
doch eine leider große mehrheit der
russischen bevölkerung die putin
propaganda glaubt ihn unterstützt und
auch diesen krieg richtig findet sobald
sie soweit überhaupt von diesem krieg
wirklich etwas wissen wie schätzen sie
das ein
dazwischen situation ist sehr schwierig
in den letzten sieben oder acht jahren
ist unsere gesellschaft einem sehr
harten experiment ausgesetzt gewesen
denn die propaganda hat in all diesen
jahren
erzählt was angeblich in der ukraine
passiert hat immer putin unterstützt hat
er klingt wie vor bei der westen ist und
das hat natürlich seinen einfluss auf
die menschen gehabt
möchte ihn zu sehen dass die russen
keinen
krieg etwas ganz furchtbares wir haben
in den großen vaterländischen krieg
durchlebte aber viel ist an verwirrungen
und es gibt unabhängige
umfragen die auch relativ hohe zahlen
zeigen aber 60 prozent das sind
diejenigen die irgendwo den krieg
unterstützen aber es gibt 30 prozent die
glauben dass russland die ukraine vor
den nazis rettet geraten
und tatsächlich nicht da ich
informationen deswegen ist es die
aufgabe was auch einer panik medien
möglichst lange ihre arbeit fortzusetzen
und davon
brauchen ja diese informationen bevor
unser kanal geschlossen wurde haben wir
drei bis vier millionen zuschauer am tag
die unsere gefolgt sind dh diese
information wird benötigt aber jetzt
scheint so eine art eiserner vorhang
runter zu gehen mit nur noch wenigen
fenstern durch die man in die welt
blicken kann
gibt es nicht man hat bei uns einige
soziale netzwerke abgeschaltet wir
erwarten auch dass youtube abgeschaltet
wird denn in youtube gibt es noch jede
menge freie information da gibt es sehr
viele professionelle journalisten die
ihre arbeit machen über youtube hat man
zugang zu allen medien zu allen kanälen
auch zu kanälen nicht unbedingt in
russland senden also da gibt es sehr
viele informationen wenn der utah
abgeschaltet wird dann wird das
wahrscheinlich
der letzte pass sein also das letzte
stück in diesem kreis geschlossen wird
aber es gibt immer noch wie pn und alle
was man auch damit um
aber das staatliche fernsehen ist
natürlich nach wie vor sehr
einflussreich leider insbesondere bei
der generation 60 plus sie haben seit
2014 den druck von putin und seinem
system gespürt als sie anfingen über den
europa dann zu berichten da merkt man
eigentlich schon wenn es um die ukraine
geht versteht bot ihm keinen spaß hätte
der westen auch früher etwas merken
müssen
ich denke man hätte das verstehen müssen
ich bin keine politikwissenschaftlerin
also das ist jetzt eher so meine super
expertise sozusagen meine persönliche
meinung viele die in russland sind
bringen dass die sanktionen aus dem jahr
2014 kein positives ergebnis hatten ich
weiß nicht was man hätte tun sollen man
musste ja irgendwie darauf reagieren
aber das hat die menschen um putin
zusammen geschweißt und für viele
menschen
die ihm nahe stehen sondern für die
normalen menschen
waren die sanktionen anschlag auf ihr
portemonnaie auf ihr leben auf ihre
sicherheit und so weiter also all diese
aktion hier eingeführt wurden und
natürlich auch die sanktionen jetzt
angeführt werden die
empfinden die normalen menschen und
deswegen passiert das was wir sehen sie
einigen sich gegen den westen den
autobahnen sogar gamma sagt ja dass der
westen diese situation hervorgerufen hat
und russland zerstören will und das will
also das nicht putin das gemacht hat
ich weiß nicht was man hätte tun sollen
das richtig gewesen wäre in dieser
situation aber ich denke das ergebnis
dass erwartet wurde ist nicht erreicht
worden mit den sanktionen
sagt natalia sind die ehe war von dort
tv ich danke ihnen sehr für das gespräch
und alles gute für sie
danke schön
dass hinter wir haben ja aufgezeichnet
wenn nun auch immer mehr russen ins exil
gehen er fährt das land auch einen
sogenannten brain brain nicht nur die
kritischen geister flüchten aus angst
vor repressionen journalisten
menschenrechtler kreative auch
wissenschaftler oder unternehmer die in
einem isolierten russland für sich keine
zukunft mehr sehen noch viel massiver
gilt als moment natürlich für die
ukraine akademiker die stadt zu forschen
zu den waffen greifen müssen
wirtschaftsstrukturen die zerstört
werden gut ausgebildete frauen die ihre
karriere hinter sich lassen und ins
ausland flüchten stefanie groß berichtet
natalia sport vertrieb der krieg aus
ihrer heimat ihr mann blieb in kiew
kämpft doch klagen will sie nicht
vielmehr vorbild sein für die zwei söhne
6 und 10 dazu gehört für die online
marketing expertin auch eigenes geld zu
verdienen
ich möchte in deutschland einen job
finden das ist wichtig denn wenn ich
hier nur um sitze dann grüble ich über
den krieg in der ukraine nach das ist
sehr schwierig für meine kinder und für
mich wenn ich arbeite dann stärkt mich
dass es gibt mir ein stück
selbstbewusstsein
kiew die ukrainische hauptstadt vor dem
krieg boomende tech metropole etwa
200.000 software entwickler auch der
berliner online händler auto dogg hat
seine it abteilung in der ukraine über
1000 mitarbeiter video-konferenz 13
november holten sie ihre leute aus den
krisenzonen brachten viele in hotels
eine grenze unter warum die ukrainischen
text spezialisten so gefragt sind
befinden junge leute hervorragend
ausgebildete leute sehr fleißig sehr
sehr hungrig etwas zu erreichen und es
geht nicht nur um die firma auch hartz
iv was jetzt sehr stark unter beschuss
ist ein ist eine stadt mit einer hohen
anzahl an
ausgebildeten sehr gut ausgebildeten
menschen das gleiche gilt auch für
odessa das unternehmen unterstützt die
online-jobbörse uk talent wie viele
andere firmen hier finden geflüchtete
ukraine in deutschland neue arbeitgeber
7000 offene stellen gibt es hinter dem
startup stecken ivano nikita ukraine die
schon länger in berlin leben
wir müssen hier langfristig denken denn
wenn wir es schaffen dass jetzt viele
ukrainische flüchtlinge für europäische
firmen arbeiten die dann vielleicht
später wieder zurückgehen weil sie in
ihrem blatt leben wollen dann werden
diese ukraine ihre kontakte in europa
mit sich tragen und die integration in
die eu passiert dann ganz natürlich
die flüchtlingskrise heute anders als
es werden vielmehr kommen vor allem
frauen und kinder
und anders als vor sieben jahren werden
die erwachsenen wald arbeiten dürfen
wird erstmal die erste humanitäre krise
bewältigt dann werden sehr viele von
diesen menschen mithilfe mit
unterstützung sehr viel beitragen können
jetzt geht es darum dass sie wenn sie
arbeiten können so schnell wie möglich
einfach um ihre identität wieder zu
bekommen dass sie nicht herumsitzen
ihnen das zu ermöglichen natalia sport
will arbeiten deutsch lernen und ihre
beiden jungs in die schule schicken aber
eigentlich würde sie lieber zurückkehren
in die heimat und ihren mann in die arme
schließen
der krieg wirft die ukraine nicht nur in
ihrer modernisierung zurück in ihrer
entwicklung zu einem und
wissenschaftsstandort sie war ja
außerdem nach wie vor ein großes
agrarland und wird auch als kornkammer
bezeichnet wenn die felder jetzt nicht
mehr gestellt werden können hat das
gewaltige folgen nicht nur für die
ukraine und nicht nur für europa wie
sich dieser krieg auf die welternährung
auswirken kann berichtet anna warsberg
diese energie kekse auf weizen basis
sind dafür da um menschen vor dem
verhungern zu bewahren sie sind auf dem
weg in die ukraine in ein land das
eigentlich einer der größten
weizenexporteure der welt ist jetzt
beherrscht der krieg die kornkammer
europas
wir haben ein land das bis vor drei
wochen sich komplett selbst versorgen
konnte wir schätzen dass jetzt schon in
der ukraine ein viertel der bevölkerung
von nahrungsmittel spenden abhängig ist
gleichzeitig sehen wir aber auch in der
ganzen welt eine scharfe verteuerung der
preise für grundnahrungsmittel vor allem
in den ländern in denen sich menschen
grundnahrungsmittel schon jetzt kaum
mehr leisten können auch durch
andauernde konflikte die folgen der
korona pandemie und den klimawandel seit
ausbruch des krieges in der ukraine
haben sich die preise pro tonne weizen
auf dem weltmarkt bereits mehr als
verdoppelt russland und die ukraine
zusammen stehen für 30 prozent der
weltweiten weizen lieferungen 20 prozent
des mais und 76 prozent der
sonnenblumenkerne das world food program
hat bisher rund 50 prozent seiner
lebensmittel aus der ukraine bezogen und
kämpft jetzt mit steigenden kosten auch
für treibstoff und transport wir haben
ja bereits vor der ukraine krise eine
situation in der wir einen hunger gürtel
um die welt haben den wir kaum meistern
können wir hatten eben eine pletzing
konferenz für jemen bei der wir nicht
genug geld erhalten haben um die
hungernden menschen in jemen
unterstützen zu können und müssen da als
eine konsequenz der von die ration
kürzen viele länder sichern ihre
politische stabilität auch durch die
subventionierung von
grundnahrungsmitteln
diese brauchen jetzt noch mehr
unterstützt um von den großen
geberländern
die lieferung müssen weitergehen die
lebensmittel sind vorhanden aber die
preise antizipieren sozusagen eine
liefer knappheit der zweite punkt ist
wir müssen schauen ob einzelne länder
finanzielle unterstützung benötigen
gerade die die überschuldet sind schon
jetzt leiden bis zu 800 elf millionen
menschen weltweit an unterernährung
die welternährungsorganisation
befürchtet dass es sieben bis 13
millionen mehr werden allein durch den
krieg in der ukraine und seine folgen
mit jedem tag der der ukraine krieg
weiter wütet wird die situation
schlimmer wir sehen ein zusammenbrechen
der infrastruktur brücken bombardiert
werden eisenbahnlinien und wenn die
schwarzmeer helfen zerstört werden
würden hätten wir eine situation in der
es jahre dauern würde bevor die ukraine
wieder produzieren kann eigentlich
sollte jetzt bald die aussaat auf den
feldern in der ukraine beginnen aber
zahlreiche bauern sind an der front
gegen russland die folgen für die
globale ernährungssituation nicht
absehbar
der wahl versucht der deutsche
wirtschaftsminister weiterhin das
energieproblem zu lösen dass mit diesem
krieg auf uns zukommt damit beginnen die
nachrichten für ein wolf minister habe
klar dazu mit einer
wirtschaftsdelegation in katar
deutschland und das emirat haben eine
langfristige energie partnerschaft
vereinbart wie habe nach seinen
gesprächen mit dem emir katers mitteilte
die unternehmen die ihn begleitet haben
würden nun mit der katarischen seite in
vertrags verhandlungen einsteigen
in der debatte um weitere sanktionen
gegen russland und die möglichen
wirtschaftlichen folgen für deutschland
etwa durch ein energie im auto geht es
nach ansicht der spd vorsitzenden esken
auch um die frage was machbar ist im
interview mit der zdf sendung berlin
direkt für wie sie unter anderem auf die
abhängigkeit der industrie von
grundstoffen und die schwierigkeiten in
die sie geraten könnte es geht
tatsächlich um funktionsfähigkeit und
handlungsfähigkeit unseres unseres
landes und wenn wir uns nicht mehr
handlungsfähig machen durch solche
entscheidungen
wäre auch niemandem geholfen aber wir
sind ganz klar drin alles zu prüfen was
möglich ist
bei den überlegungen der ampel koalition
zur entlastung der bürger soll
arbeitsminister heil jetzt ein
mobilitäts geld ins spiel gebracht haben
der bild am sonntag sieht das konzept
eine nach einkommen gestaffelte
entlastung vor profitieren sollen
bezieher von kleinen und mittleren
einkommen
in belgien ist ein auto am frühen morgen
in eine personengruppe gerast mindestens
sechs menschen wurden dabei getötet sind
weitere schweben in lebensgefahr
der zwischenfall ereignete sich rund 50
kilometer südwestlich von brüssel dort
hatten sich bis zu 200 menschen für eine
karnevalsfeier versammelt die beiden
insassen des wagens wurden festgenommen
die staatsanwaltschaft geht derzeit
nicht von einem terrorakt aus
zur corona situation das
robert-koch-institut hat binnen 24
stunden
131 1792 neuinfektionen registriert das
sind 14 1815 weniger als vergangenen
sonntag 49 todesfälle kamen hinzu die
sieben tage incidents ist erstmals seit
mehr als zwei wochen gesunken auf etwa
1700 8
ab heute gilt das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz wobei die
betonung daher nicht mehr so sehr auf
schutz liegt nach dem neuen bundesgesetz
sollen fast alle ein dämmungsmaßnahmen
wegfallen die meisten bundesländern
nutzen allerdings eine übergangsfrist
bis anfang april
insofern ändert sich vielerorts erst mal
noch nicht so viel dafür wächst die
kritik daran mitten in infektions
höchststände hinein sogar die masken
pflicht weitgehend weg zu lassen ähnlich
hat es österreich gehandhabt schon vor
zwei wochen das ist dann aber nicht so
gut gelaufen bei unseren nachbarn die
sieben tage inzidenz liegt dort jetzt
bei über
3600 das hat folgen und so kehrt
österreich nun hast dich zur masken
pflicht zurück wolf christian ullrich
berichtet
österreichs gesundheitsminister ist seit
zwei wochen im amt und zeigt schon die
politische pirouette gerade noch die
maske abgesetzt kehrtwende angesichts
rekord infektionen
wie sie sinnvoll überall dort maske zu
tragen muss möglichst eben auch in
innenräumen eben auch am arbeitsplatz
egal wo man sich aufhält die masken
pflicht geht voraussichtlich ab mittwoch
sie wurde notwendig weil fünf prozent
der bevölkerung corona hat darunter auch
soviel krankenhauspersonal dass in
einigen kliniken die versorgung
gefährdet ist ein krankenhaus hat nun
den notstand erklärt
das wird dort wo es auch möglich ist
dass die operationen verschieben so wie
wir das auch in der vergangenheit getan
haben dass wir die eben verschieben die
berater kommission der regierung hatte
deshalb vor vorschnellen lockerungen der
korona maßnahmen gewarnt ein
gesundheitsmanager verließ nun aus
protest die kommission
sterben etwa 200 menschen ihre woche an
diesem nach zu milden und mikro corona
virus und das wird durch nur
achselzuckend und billigend zur kenntnis
genommen und der spagat zwischen
vorsicht und sorglosigkeit hat
inzwischen zwei gesundheitsminister
verschlissen wolfgang mückstein schmiss
vor zwei wochen hinein grund ständige
bedrohung
es mag dann nennen wenn die eigene
wohnung rund um die uhr von der polizei
bewacht werden muss
mitverantwortlich dafür ein zunehmend
aggressiver zusammenschluss von
impfgegnern holocaust verharmlosen und
rechtsextremen der fast wöchentlich
durch österreichs hauptstadt marschiert
und die abschaffung der korona maßnahmen
fordert
[Musik]
impfpflicht ausgesetzt party gastronomie
geöffnet gratis massentest sollen
auslaufen und das alles mitten in der
fünften welle der eindruck drängt sich
auf die schwarz grüne regierung von
bundeskanzler neheimer höre er auf qik
ezb als auf die eigenen
gesundheitsexperten
war es vor wenigen wochen so dass man
eben öffnungen weitestgehend sehr rasch
kommunizieren wollte zu einer unzeit wie
damals schon expertinnen und experten
aus dem gesundheitsbereich moniert haben
gibt man jetzt klarer weise wieder dem
druck nach das ist einfach zu
unhaltbaren zuständen wieder in den
krankenhäusern kommt also die politik
ist dann nur mehr getrieben und eine
klare linie ist in dieser situation
überhaupt nicht mehr gegeben jeder
zwanzigste österreicher ist derzeit in
quarantäne
die neue masken pflicht scheint jetzt
das kleinste zumutbare übel mal sehen ob
es dabei bleibt und
jetzt zum sport an diesem wochenende und
zunächst zur fußball bundesliga da gab
es heute diese ergebnisse rb leipzig
eintracht frankfurt 0 0 wolfsburg
leverkusen 0 2 und erste fc köln
borussia dortmund eins zu eins
beim weltcup-finale im norwegischen oslo
hat sich biathletin franziska preuß
platz zwei im massenstart gesichert
hinter der französin breza boucher im
letzten rennen seiner karriere verpasste
erik lesser beim massenstart der männer
das podium nur knapp der frühere doppel
weltmeister und olympia
silbermedaillengewinner leistete sich
beim liegend schießen zwei fehler und
kam schließlich als vierter ins ziel
die formel 1 ist in die neue saison
gestartet ferrari-pilot charlie claire
hat den grand prix von bahrain gewonnen
schale claire im ferrari rechts gewinnt
von der pole position aus den staat
weltmeister max verstappen lange zeit
dicht an seinem heck mitte des rennens
mehrere attacken des niederländers doch
der monegasse content bleibt vorne die
entscheidung drei runden vor rennende
verstappen mit technischen defekt raus
bahn frei für schale claire erster
grand-prix-sieg der scuderia seit 910
tagen auf zwei carlos sainz junior
ebenfalls ferrari lewis hamilton wird
dritter mit schumacher guter elfter
und zum schluss blicken wir noch mal
nach berlin dort haben heute wie auch in
anderen deutschen städten erneut
tausende gegen den krieg protestiert
am brandenburger tor gab es zudem ein
großes friedens und benefiz konzert mit
viel deutscher pop und rock prominenz
aber auch mit ukrainischen und
russischen künstlern stefanie heil und
stefan persch waren für uns dabei
[Musik]
diesen
vom frieden träumen und für den frieden
in der ukraine auf die straße gehen seit
dem mittag wird vor dem brandenburger
tor demonstriert und dazu gesungen eine
friedenskundgebung der kultur und
musikbranche
also wir brauchen ja auch nicht naiv
seine musik kann nicht alles aber musik
kann kann verbinden musik an brücken
bauen und musik kann auf jeden fall auch
zeigen dass das alles irgendwie verwoben
ist wir gehören irgendwie alle zusammen
und das sieht man auch heute hier wir
werden heute ein statement abgeben
können weil ich es man nicht übersehen
kann und ich bin froh dass wir anteil an
dieser ganzen initiative sind ist
natürlich ein zeichen im mosaik oder
promillebereich so aber
auch das ist wichtig
[Musik]
denn gerade mal zwei wochen haben die
veranstalter das programm auf die bühne
gestellt um die 50 auftritte sie sammeln
spenden für organisationen die den
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer jetzt helfen
wir glauben ganz fest daran dass die
kraft der musik dazu hilft uns ein
kleines stück bessere welt zu bestehen
da bin ich ganz fest davon überzeugt
[Musik]
natalia klitschko die frau des käfer
bürgermeisters singt über ihr
angegriffenes land und über die hoffnung
wenn wir der staat jedem landwirt sowie
berlin heute auf steht dann können wir
zusammen was wir gegen ich glaube daran
ich bin fest überzeugt
der schrott vergangener kriege steckt in
dieser glocke ein mädchen aus der
ukraine und ein junge aus russland
leuten sie heute gemeinsam
minuten im ersten und zweiten weltkrieg
wurden ungefähr 150.000 kirchenglocken
geschlagen um waffen herzustellen und
ich habe diesen prozess umgekehrt ich
habe aus granat hülsen patronenhülsen
die wirklich in kriegsgebieten benutzt
wurden eine friedensglocke geschmiedet
und das ist die piesberg 3
[Musik]
und sie sind gekommen für elf stunden
der solidarität
[Musik]
noch kurz zu den wetteraussichten morgen
gibt es im nordwesten wolken sonst
scheint die sonne der südostwind weht
mäßig aber durch zehn grad werden es an
der ostsee 19 grad am niederrhein die
nächsten tage bringen frühlingssonne von
früh bis spät am kühlsten bleibt es mit
elf grad an den küsten sonst kommen wir
immer häufiger der 20 grad marke nein
das war es von uns morgen erwarten singe
christian sievers heinz wolf und um 0.20
gibt es die nächste heute express wieder
sie
[Musik]